in a wheat field north of kiev a
demining expert sweeps for the weapons
of war
the mine detector finds remnants of a
cluster bomb
it's slow going but these workers need
to clear a path before farming combines
can reap the wheat from a wartime
harvest
they're among a thousand demining
experts across ukraine racing to avert a
global food shortage
behind me we have found a fragment of
class ammunition and a grenade from an
rpg-7 which is unexploded
when the war began this farm was
attacked by russian aircraft artillery
and cluster bombs workers had to replace
tractors trucks and barns before they
could bring in the harvest
you can see they're burned and destroyed
by shelling artillery and drone strikes
as farmers scramble to gather wheat corn
and sunflower oil russia and ukraine
have reached a tenuous agreement to
allow 20 million tons of trapped
ukrainian grain to leave from black sea
ports through so-called safe channels
but with all the dangers of transporting
the crop of 2022 in a war zone for now
this farm is storing wheat in these
containers
wheat is the symbol of ukraine that
yellow and blue flag represents a field
of wheat beneath the sky of blue
and for ukraine the problem is getting
this wheat out of the ports
but for farms like this the problem is
overcoming all of the obstacles to get
it harvested in the first place
the harvest of war has been tough on
farms across ukraine russia has left its
signature on these cluster bombs
here we can see the mark of russian
forces since the beginning of our work
our employees found this on our field
the machinery of war rushes the machines
on the farm
and as summer winds to a close the race
to bring in this year's crop grows more
urgent every day
john hendren al jazeera krasnaya ukraine